these people don't understand what
communism is they don't they don't
understand what socialism is No so
they're like the police are an
oppressive force and what do you think
you would get if you had communism do
you think there would be no police do
you think like you'd be way worse they
seem to think like each and every one of
these people these communists believe
that if communism is implemented there
the party leader yeah well oh won't
affect well no I'm gonna be the leader
I'm not gonna have to work yeah you have
to work the farms now yeah no no no
everyone would go out and work the farms
and I try I try warning my dumb friends
who are probably gonna listen to this in
a bit like is he talking about me
because they don't understand what
happens after you you get your socialist
or communist revolution right do you
know you know you know who they're gonna
go after first the okay let's it these
violent lefties far-left authoritarians
all of a sudden your mass protests
sparks an opportunity for a literal
revolution and now you've got
authoritarian communists in control
they're going to purge the leftist that
the liberal intellectuals like you on
Twitter because you were the one who
fomented the revolution in the first
place get it yeah is there ii don't want
to happen again exactly exactly they
need to make sure that any revolutionary
who would stop their takeover is put
down first and you make an example of
them right what do you mean like you
need to come down on them heavily I
would think so that everyone knows
everyone knows it's gonna happen again
yeah so it I'm not I've been told this
is a big thing that they've done
historically mmm-hmm you know reading
about communist revolutions and they
immediately say now that we've won this
writer and this intellectual who helped
create the atmosphere that generated
revolution needs to die and so I was
talking my friends I'm like let's let's
think about this for two seconds like
let's entertain this idea who are they
more concerned about the Conservatives
who keep their mouths shut and hide in
their homes or the Liberals who are out
demanding revolution the bigger threat
are the people who are willing to get up
and demand a revolution true so liberals
get the bullet too they say and that's
and that's you know when I was reading
about the Spanish Civil War and
you know Mr Germany or is it von Maur
Germany they both factions target
liberals like John Cleese said in that
segment pure moderate moderate they're
coming for you everybody hates yeah yeah
but for the left they need weed out the
competition they need to make sure that
no one challenges them right and there's
there's there's there's a similar
example of this because it's probably
true of any take over if the Communists
take over and it's the left they purged
them their own salient faction but in
Egypt when they had the second
revolution and they got rid of Morsi
they went and started act just gunning
down Muslim Brotherhood so the Muslim so
what happened in Egypt was they had the
first revolution where mobar got pulled
out and he was the military leader and
then they had an election the Muslim
Brotherhood won because they were the
biggest voting bloc and they just vote
for whatever the Muslim Brotherhood said
this resulted in the overwhelming
majority of the country rejecting this
again and the protest continued because
they mostly wanted a secular government
so then they finally I was out I was
there for this when they finally removed
Morsi and then like I'm watching the a
PCS roll up and people are riding on him
and they shot the bridges down it was
nuts
they got their Revolution then because
the mother Muslim Brotherhood would not
stop the you know protests the military
just went out and started shooting live
rounds and anybody who kept protesting
wow yeah so the people who initially
fought for the revolution even won their
position then got removed again so it's
not it's not it's on the exact same type
of scenario but if you are the hip of
person that won't allow the revolution
take place like you you started there
they're gonna come for you they're gonna
come right for you and be like you were
part of the problem how many
conservatives right now are out
protesting not that many know most of
the moderates and the Conservatives are
in their homes preparing for themselves
take care of themselves definitely
people don't know their names but you've
got a big list of revolutionaries and
they're all on the left it's true yeah
so when these these lunatics take over
yeah they're they're gonna go for the
counter revolutionaries for sure so you
know there are a lot of conservatives
who are high-profile who would be
targeted by them if and when they ever
you know if slash when they ever did get
power but for the most part you have a
much bigger list I believe of
like lefty intellectual revolutionary
types who want power so it goes back to
the point we're making all of these
people seem to think they're gonna be
Dear Leader yeah they're gonna be
privileged and in the party when the
takeover happens and you look at what
happens in the in in the Chas some
random dude takes over declares himself
the new police and everyone's going oh
no oh no oh no what do we do I guess
that's the way it is now yeah so well
I'll put it this way let's say you've
got a hundred SOI boy intellectual types
who are on Twitter not right now
tweeting like this is the revolution
it's time for us to rise up these people
have no capability what's over to lead
to be in charge but there are going to
be some physically fit trained
insurrectionary leftists not good people
not good people they've got weapons
they're zealots and they're gonna be
like who's my biggest threat these
people want my power they helped start
the revolution in the first place I
think we need we know who needs to go
first
yeah that's why they spray-painted on
the wall and Berkeley liberal liberals
get the bullet too they're not gonna
meet look if they defeat the so it's
like the assumption is they defeat
whatever side they need you to win and
then they have to figure out which which
on undesirables go first
it's the ones who have influence and
would challenge your power not the dude
sitting in this house clutching his gun
saying leave me alone and that's what
you can expect if the chance expands
yeah
no I'm half kidding I don't I don't
think apparently they trying to do
something in Portland do you see the
video what they're now trying to create
a bunch of Chaz like states across the
country
so like Nashville is gonna try and do a
show in Portland they grabbed a barbed
wire fence and like tried to create a
barricade they're like I did see that
trying to take over I guess it failed I
don't know I love how they love border
walls now though seems to be like their
thing yeah they work crazy yeah man but
it seems all performative you know yeah
like they they don't they they're
playing a game but they don't realize
that the prizes are real like you know
they think yeah or maybe they don't
think they're playing a game maybe they
actually think it's the Revolution and
they're just really dumb that's so sad
pathetic I feel bad for them I'm not on
the chaz subreddit
there's a thread now about how
everyone's making fun of their garden
and like trying to give advice to like
fix it yeah I won't get rid of all of
the grass in that entire field turn that
entire field into a garden because
you're gonna need yeah that much that's
probably not even good it's not even
enough I have an idea even not even
here's an idea here's my idea for them
they need to go back in time about two
and a half months plant everything when
it's in the way that it's supposed to be
planted and then maybe they might have
enough food for like well it's Seattle
winters in Seattle aren't known for
being very very cold yeah I remember I
was in a I was in Seattle man what was
this 14 years ago fifty thirteen years
ago and it's snowed really and then the
whole city shut down and people were
panicking it's colder today because the
hills so man the hills in Seattle are
steep that's true and when it rains it's
like sometimes it was like one time that
was raining so hard in Slippery I had
trouble actually walking up the hill so
I lived in in Fremont which is what is
that like north of Queen and I think I'm
not entirely sure and either walk over
Venice yeah this big hill it was it the
26th Street bridge it's been over no
idea right yes yes maybe I can pull up
this map and look at where it was so
yeah it's right here I think right here
this is that 26 Aurora bridge I lived
like right over here okay maybe I'm
wrong about the name of the bridge was
zero Aurora bridge so I had to walk up
right here and there's a steep steep
hill okay and it'd be raining when it
snowed everybody was panicking because
the cars would just slide down the hill
oh my gosh so they couldn't handle a
little bit of snow no so what do you
think is gonna happen if it gets cold I
don't know if it'll get cold or whatever
but I guess it rained if this makes it
to winter I think we're gonna we're
gonna have a lot of get your popcorn
ready it's like my popcorns been ready
oh man don't worry I know how to make
more popular tonight here's here's it
you got to be careful of right oh do
tell me Tim you see what the Chas is is
basically alike it's like a Venus Venus
flytrap right you know you see this this
this sweetness and it attracts you to
and then
grabs your eyes the delicious nectar
smell in the air yes yes what is it and
so what I mean by this is when you watch
the the the when you look at the photos
and the videos of their desperate
pathetic attempts at whatever it is
they're doing yeah like putting potted
plants on top of dirt middle part you
laugh and then you let your guard down
yeah and then the crazy people expand
their borders and that's the trick
that's that's the that's the adaptation
to survive yeah convincing you they're
harmless
so you ignore them while they expand
take more territory and spread out yeah
that that's actually I mean to be like
to be to be real to be honest that is a
real concern I have that people are
gonna be laughing at them the whole time
other people I think are over hyping it
you know everything like oh man look
what they're doing but I do think
there's a possibility that this could
get worse if they don't put it under
keep it under control
what's to stop them from moving the
barriers out just taking more space well
I guess it's only go until the 20th so
says the governor no you're right I
don't know what exactly that end date
means but I don't know it is kind of
weird that they would have an end date
why what's it's Friday I think tomorrow
and Sunday might be really really
interesting because the economy is
opening back up I know a lot of people
out of work but typically weekends
always light up for these things okay so
during Occupy Wall Street when I first
arrived it was during the week there was
nothing there okay nobody there I kid
you not it was like 10 people and so it
was being a bunch of other people
standing under a tarp in the rain and
some like ranking cop walks up in a
trench you know in like a raincoat and
he waves and he laughs and he's like
he's like good luck and he walks off
there was nobody in the park right it
was just like the remnants of the first
you know a few days of Occupy because I
got there like day four or something but
then that weekend thousand two thousand
people some ridiculous numbers showed up
you got to understand that wouldn't
surprise me if that's what happening
like right now exactly you even said it
like people around the country are
probably flocking to Chaz
yes become Chaz citizens yep you know
and have their their true freedom again
what happens when they add another two
hundred people could be bad well that
farm isn't gonna be enough they're
across their borders
they're gonna need more space yeah and
so they're all they got to do is move
the barricade up so interestingly in one
article I read from The Daily Mail the
new map they have actually shows
expanded territory Oh
so the original map showed they only had
half of the park the new map shows
they've taken the whole park and
barricaded around it oh my goodness but
I don't I don't know if that's true I
hope not but what would stop him what's
gonna stop them doesn't seem like the
government in in Washington cares here's
there's a possibility they know what's
going on you think so yeah I think he
knew what was going on when that
reporter asked him and he was like oh
what's that ballet or whatever did you
do you have a good source a reputable
source he said it's like what no it's
it's it's deniability he's like I don't
I don't know anything about it so I'm
good yeah he knows he knew exactly what
they were talking about come on yeah
what happens if the first few days the
first one it's been five days right yeah
and so people have to get they need time
to get there and you've got a small
handful of like John Brown gun club but
CNN did this report where they said
there's potential for bloodshed if they
try to get remove them or what about
when the next potential warlord comes
and goes razzed you're not doing a good
job then what no one elected you no
one's gonna elect me
I'm warlord now well I got a better
right but then what no but what happens
when that guy who shows up actually has
five guys with yeah with long guns and
then people start getting shot where do
those people go well what happens right
now if somebody walked in but what would
happen right now if somebody walked in
there and said look at me I'm in charge
now yeah they said no and then he went
Shh I'm in charge now
and what are they gonna do they're gonna
back okay okay okay yep yeah probably
what are they to do what are they gonna
do nothing that's what I fear yeah is
any of these John Brown gun club people
gonna shoot the guy nope I really doubt
it they might they might [ __ ] their
weapons and be like I just don't know
you don't believe I don't believe it I
don't know I have no idea
but I know I I sense something like that
coming soon yeah you think yeah I mean
they've already drawn weapons on people
apparently really the rasz crew
apparently pulled
or something I've seen them I've seen
them beat people up yeah yep there's
video surfacing of them fighting amongst
themselves now it's like it's only a
matter of time before someone says
you're not doing a good enough job
whereas I'm taking that's already
happening exactly try to get rid of them
but they're going in the other direction
they're trying to like get rid of him in
general not replace him oh sure
well here's here's I'm thinking until
he's gone and then it gets replaced yeah
what would happen what would happen if
you know you've got people probably
traveling there from across the country
right now far-left crazies who are armed
and one revolution and want to be in
charge and what happens if they show up
and say now we're doing this you know
this is the best chance period shut up
all the people were there waiting to do
are they gonna leave are they gonna be
like or are they gonna be like okay I
think you know a lot of them will leave
yeah but then if you've created a space
where a bunch of people can come in it's
possible that these far lefties do it in
the right way you if they come in with
weapons start shooting people then it's
over you know instantly over Trump's
gonna send in the military and people
will beg and thank him for it true but
if all of these people start flocking to
Chaz and then all they really do is push
the barricade up ten feet in each
direction no don't do anything don't say
anything at once a day yep
every day push it up 10 feet yeah and
then start taking more and more space
well it feels like a lot of the citizens
of Washington that don't live in Seattle
are like have at it yeah they've been
upset with the way that the government's
been handling that state anyway so it's
like I have a feeling like states are
gonna start seceding splitting up the
divided States of America has come on I
gotta base I doubt it
I think the sentiment perhaps because
they already wanted to though which they
were already talking about cutting ties
with Seattle Oh citizen yeah they're
like we don't want anything to do with
these people these are the conservatives
right saying get out of here yeah yeah
these are people who saw the crazy left
people that live there are they're all
gonna live in harmony until you know it
annoys me a certain warlord it annoys me
comes along but they don't they never do
anything you've got you've got the
basically 99% of the terror
taury of which of washington yeah is
conservative right now the population
wise they have the big city of seattle
which is overwhelmingly progressive okay
who's happy with any of it and why can't
they just say we're done you take your
city we're done same thing for new york
that's what I'm all that's if I think is
gonna happen there was there was
somebody sent me a message saying that
there they advocate for the blue city's
becoming their own jurisdiction yes and
separating away from the conservative
areas otherwise there will be bloodshed
yeah that actually makes sense
yeah but then what how do you how do you
how do you govern that I does that work
yeah like these cities would collapse
overnight well first step get rid of the
police well they got that done what's
next all the businesses are leaving the
businesses are already leaving they
actually left already so so now they're
gonna have no businesses and no police
force what's what is there gonna be it's
not a city anymore it's not everyone's
now they're being flattened yeah okay so
it just becomes a regular town that's
its Nadu and not even you know it's
gonna happen to Minneapolis hmm we
talked about Detroit right Chicago is
talking about I think I have this I have
this right here Chicago mayor considers
property tax hikes as residents fear
exodus from city yeah that's gonna make
people want to stay yeah they have a
choice doesn't they have a choice why
they they don't have a choice
they can't leave if they want city has
no choice they have to raise the taxes
the infrastructure to run the trains
yeah does not go down well cost of the
more they do that the more people will
leave yep the more they do that yeah the
more people leave and exactly continue
and continue just like oh it lives there
anymore
just like the choice like Detroit yep
because the a Chicago you're doing it
wrong yep but there's nothing they can
do it's it's it's they're they're in a
trap they have no idea how to escape
it's quicksand yeah and they're
struggling and they're sinking faster
and faster and faster it's true that's
gonna happen so Minneapolis says we're
getting rid of our police everyone
desperately tries to sell you know it's
crazy man could you imagine if you
finally saved up you know you turn 30
and you're like I got a you know I got
like 20 grand saved up for a down
payment finally after all these years
and that's piyah not a lot of people who
have that yeah you then bite you you buy
in Minneapolis you know it's your town
your city
and you buy a nice little house now the
whole city is in is in chaos
yeah the police departments being
abolished and you're like can I sell and
then you look at the property value and
it's down 70% you lost basically all
your money everything gone and now
you're underwater you owe more than the
house is worth you could never leave you
know dude these people don't understand
and then the property value tanks and
then the taxes tank with it and then the
city starts making no revenue and then
the water lines fall apart so they tap
into water nearby which is full of
Legionnaires disease and and whatever
whatever else disease is yep just like
Flint and then the majority of people
that are lower-class
increases yep the money funnels through
to the the richest people which is what
they're supposed there is you walk away
well no they're sitting pretty in their
comfortable palaces wherever that is
it's not right cities yeah I mean
Minneapolis even the people who own good
real estate in the city like penthouses
and stuff yeah they don't care so like
uh our water bill went up another three
hundred dollars whatever okay yeah
there's mean anything they don't care it
makes no difference to them but
considering all the chaos and the
violence they as soon as this happened a
lot of these listings are probably like
investment properties you know or
companies you know from from companies
or something you know maybe rental
properties I'm sure some of them are
people who actually live there I think
most more probable people fleeing but
that's the thing that people don't
realize like because I also did a
there's a story came out the private
security is skyrocketing
right yeah I've been seeing them because
people you know because of the chaos so
the people that can afford it are just
getting their own private security
that's how that works
yeah yeah so here's the meme is they
vote to abolish the police yeah rich
people that hire private security then
the left starts complaining about how
the poor people have no security and
demand security for all security and
then they've amended the police everyone
has a right to police correct yeah this
is what they don't understand as they
burn their city to the ground
they're gonna get a rude awakening in
the fact that they don't make anything
you know that's a good point that's what
I'm looking at these the the farms on a
Mike man they have no idea what it takes
to live on your own
if the bluesy by yourself if the blue
areas of this country got cut off from
the red areas yeah they would implode
they would it was completely implode yep
people talk about California California
produces a third of our agriculture our
something like that right do you hear
the the truckers there's a the trucker
union is going we're not gonna we're not
gonna drive into cities wow we're done
we will not deliver to those cities it's
like okay well that's how those cities
get everything yeah so you you're not
gonna get anything anymore
yeah I have fun truckers have a bike
strike is the final that's it yeah you
don't come all the truckers working for
you well good good luck we'll look at
the trucker who tried in was it where
was that was that la la yeah they
grabbed his they pulled him out they
beat him up they took his phone and
opened up and looked through his texts
yeah and then he said some someone said
something like you know are you gonna do
this run and he says you know I'm gonna
have to do it cuz nobody else will you
know they took that and tried to make it
seem like he was actually saying I'm
gonna run them over because no one else
will what he was really saying is that
this payload for the that needs to be
delivered nobody wants to do it because
the protests but I'll take it
yeah and one has to give him the food
give him these people well I think it
was like some liquid it was like a man
the truckers are like the the blood of
literally a buddy who's a trucker and
Chicago it's like man they they do so
much work yeah
zoom out look at look at United Sates
and zoom out on Google Maps and look at
all of the interstate roads you know and
imagine all of the little trucks like
red blood cells carrying oxygen and
much-needed supplies to the cities
exactly exactly they don't get it man we
we drove across the country for the
Rogan podcast during the pandemic yep
and truckers were still out doing their
thing like totally normal yeah keeping
keeping the production line
there's no never live with no truckers
there's no snowboards there's no shoes
nothing and then and then I'll tell you
what man I ordered a bunch of shirts
many of you may notice I'm wearing a
different colors I actually ordered a
bunch of shirts right didn't come like a
month went by or longer so we and I'm
liked it's kind of weird I wonder if
they got looted and I got an email I got
okay saying you know you're shipping
your shipment is delayed we're so sorry
uh-huh then finally a month later the
box shows up I wonder if they got
noticed like the it was all looted and
in order to complete the order I don't
know for sure but what I do know this I
do know is this
I ordered a skate ramp and I got an
email saying specifically because of an
taifa they were delayed because the
warehouse had had to be evacuated due to
Antipa right now like that's all they
gave you didn't give any details man I
would have been had a submission I got
an email it basically said due to anti
fact if 'ti warehouse was evacuated we
were unable to complete the order we're
hoping to get it to you as soon as
possible but it could be it's gonna be
delayed now a couple weeks Wow yeah and
I saw that an email started laughing I'm
like due to an tyfa activities yeah I
guess I can only imagine that the PR
department or like the the the the sales
department for this company is going
like how do we explain this to people
what are we saying how do we explain to
them that their order can't come in yeah
and what an tyfa is dude you know what
man
i don't know but i see these videos of
people with skateboards whacking people
i see that too I don't believe those
date borders no I don't think I do not
believe they're skateboarders yeah
that's a hint maybe a few of them are
yeah but posers you think so I think my
cream wears I think they ride
skateboards all supreme doubt doubt what
I what I mean is they're probably people
who have skateboards they're definitely
not people who know how to do skateboard
tricks yeah maybe a little bit here and
there they're the ones that are like you
see them get on their board and they
like struggle to find their balance and
then riot straight stiff cruise around
I'm riding I'm riding no they they don't
really even know to do that they can go
some rate some of the so some of the
board's I saw were like really old
destroy boards yeah and that says to me
they're not part of the of the culture
in the community yeah because I've seen
skateboarders get into fights with
security guards but typically
skateboarders are like I don't know they
flee when conflict arises are like they
jump on your board you get out unless of
course you're trying to get that trick
of that one spot
you can't start a fight and then want
the trick you got but here's the other
thing too is of all of the skateboarders
I know who are legit skateboarders
nobody wants to break their board
absolutely now I'm gonna whack some with
your boards like whoa well you'd punch
somebody before easier before it's
actually not a cop yeah the waters are
way too apathetic to do this right the
the most I've seen from skateboarders is
during this all this black lives matter
stuff is like the barracks okay you know
the barracks
yeah it's like those are familiar it's a
big skate website and skate park they've
been posting a ton of stuff and you know
what the most they're doing is they're
posting clips from famous black pro
skateboarders that are like like great
clips yeah and they're just doing the
normal thing you see from the PR like
you know we're trying to you know prop
up some you know skaters the community
and keep make you aware of like their
skills or whatever and I'm like
skateboarding skateboard oh man okay
we're good skaters I don't got a good
tricks I'm not I'm not I'm not
necessarily a fan because all I care
about I watch is are they doing good
tricks yeah yeah and that's all that
matters to me if they start putting up
people who are like really bad at
skateboarding I'd be like come on man
yeah like you don't got a place no but
they're good skateboarder there's been
really cool clips yeah so is that is
that it yes you see these skateboarders
going around whacking people and I'm
like nah you're a skateboarder there's
one video going viral where they whack a
cop yeah I'm like dude no way yeah in
Miami right is that yeah yeah and then
there's a right now there's a few
skaters and it's like the I mean they
take a board no they just freakin boom
on the guy's head oh like that could
kill somebody right are you trying to
kill the man probably what why is is
that where riot Bay was I'm not sure
going viral no it's like a very
attractive Miami woman oh yeah they were
they were using that riot bags ready man
I respect that yeah yeah anyway man I
don't know where we all go with the
stuff but when you see the mortgages
start spiking yeah my so Cassandra
Fairbanks for instance mhm yeah she left
yep she's yeah anyway oh you see I'm
pretty sure she was in DC yeah yeah but
like I don't think she was anywhere near
the protest or whatever I think she she
she published a video or audio recording
of when she called 9-1-1 and she's
freaking out like they're shooting in my
house yeah yeah if you go if you follow
I think her twitter handle is Kat
caste rules Cassandra Fairbanks she
posted the audio recording of the 911
call when she called and they're like
she's like they're shooting at my house
what do we do she bugged out for obvious
reasons surprising the funny thing
though is I'm seeing a bunch of people
like posting on Facebook how many of you
want to move to West Virginia my time to
go I feel bad for West Virginia you know
why all these city folk moving and
bringing their policies and their
problems yeah that's what a lot of
Texans are complaining about what
Colorado to complain about non-stop so
many Californians are moving to Texas
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you